dungeon ryu coming off a rough outing
last time out to give up three home runs
and another change it's hit to left
center field goriel makes another diving
catch
his second in as many days
curveball from ryu on the inside corner
strike three on conforto
first and second and two out and dom
smith the batter
and dom loops one at the left center
field that's going to fall for a base
hit mcneil around third and heading home
the throw is cut off and now they've got
uh
wonderful drop between third and home
and finally frazier is tagged out for
the third out
last of the first inning the mets have
given david peterson a run to work with
eighth pitch of the at-bat coming to
guerrero and he chops one back to
peterson nice snag by david and that
retires the side he's got to at least
consider the possibility of a bun
rosario
showed on the first pitch and now a
ground ball this could be two
and it is the ardo espinal and back to
guerrero
and here's lourdes goriel jr looking for
his first hit in the series he's over
eight through the first couple of games
and he drives one to left field and
there is no doubt about it
a long home the blue jays take the lead
that's the way to get your first hit of
the series
a two-run home run and one that was a
tape measure
shot in his seventh of the season
and that'll get todd frazier in it bad
there goes the runner and
it's strike three call frazier may not
like that one either
so now bechet who grounded out his first
time up
and he struck him out with a high
fastball so peterson goes upstairs to
get pachette
for his first strike out of the
afternoon
nobody out in the fourth inning ryu has
recorded nine outs
and allowed seven hits
why not stay with it right three in a
row and he got him
yeah why change when you see a guy
flailing at a particular pitch
on the corner he got him strike three
called
two on two out and he got him what a job
by hunji and ryu strikes out the side
and strands a pair of mets that's
looking for some good vibrations in
buffalo
there's a swing of the midst of the
curveball davis is struck out for the
second half
jd davis a fly out and a ground out
today
swing and a miss and davis strikes out
well that's a good change up and henry
fires his first
one two three inning against the mets
ryu
back out there for the sixth inning he's
retired five in a row
and then he gets jammed and biggio
cutting in front of espinal makes the
play
at third base he has gone through six
innings on 91 pitches
full count and all four
and brock really unhappy with chad
fairchild
and fairchild just told him to knock it
off took his mask off
didn't like what he heard from brock and
the bases are now loaded three batters
three walks
and jared hughes inheriting a tough spot
inside ball four that'll force in a run
to make it three to one
here is santiago espinal
line fair down the left field wide
brechik is in to score glorious in the
score
vr is on his way home and he'll score
espinal clears the bases and it's six to
one
a three-run double for espinal he takes
third on the throw home
and now janssen flares one over the
drawn in infield for a base hit
to bring home another run they have
kicked the door
wide open here in the bottom of the
sixth inning and so now frazier one out
of three
single struck out slide to left
that's lining to right center field to
base it for frazier and that'll get a
run in
jd davis will come in to score on the
third goes conforto so three straight
hits for the mets to start this eighth
inning
and they've got some life it's now 7-2
toronto
and dom rolls one down to first guerrero
goes to second gets the force there no
relay
as a run comes home and it's now 7-3
up the middle what a play what a catch
by
jonathan vr raphael dulis comes in not a
save situation it's a four run lead
and he got it golease will finish it off
and the blue jays will take two out of
three from the mets
and stay ahead of the yankees for second
place